if you're impressed by the dragons on
the new game of thrones prequel house of
the dragon get ready a bigger beast is
on its way
showrunners have promised that we'll see
at least 17 dragons in total including
at least nine in the first season two
episodes into the buzzy news show's
first season audiences have already met
a few massive dragons including cyrax
and karaxis who belong to princess
rhaenyra targaryen and prince damon
targaryen respectively we've also heard
about belarion the black dread whose
skull now rests in the cellars of the
red keep and dream fire whose egg was
chosen for rhaenyra's late brother then
stolen by damon however according to a
fascinating tidbit mentioned by the
young lady lena velarion there's another
way bigger dragon lurking somewhere out
in the world
do you know where veigar is now
uh
the dragon keepers believe she made home
somewhere on the coast of the narrow sea
as audiences prepare to see a
legendarily large chekhov's dragon show
up some people might be asking what's
the deal with this dragon a massive
female steed named vegar in the original
book series by george rr martin a song
of ice and fire veigar is mentioned
briefly by tyrion lannister and her
basic stats are pretty intense for
starters tyrion notes that veigar is so
massive that a soldier could easily ride
a horse down her throat martin writes in
a game of thrones that tyrion knew
vegard's size because he saw her skull
up close as cersei saw belarions in
season seven tyrion had stood between
their gaping jaws wordless and odd you
could have ridden a horse down veigar's
gullet although you would not have
ridden it out again in a clash of kings
martin writes that veigar's breath was
so hot that it could melt a knight's
armor and cook the man inside so what is
fagar's importance to the game of
thrones prequel in episode 2 king
viserys tells lady laina that he's not
100 sure where vegar is at the moment
but confirms that she's far too large to
reside in the dragon pits of king's
landing anyway but vague arsenal lives
somewhere
but too large for the dragon pit
some would say too large for our world
while it's unsettling that viserys and
his advisors seem to have you know lost
track of an enormous fire-breathing
murder machine there's little doubt that
veigar will appear in the series
eventually some fans think this dragon
from the fire will rain teaser is vegar
but that hasn't been confirmed yet
martin's books also tell us that veigar
was almost as large as belarion and was
ridden by one of king aegon's sister
wives visenya during aegon's conquest
the continent conquering campaign that
made house targaryen what it is during
the events of house of the dragon
i'm worried for all of us
they say every time a targaryen is born
the gods toss a coin and the world holds
its breath to say much more about
vegar's role in fire and blood the
source material for house of the dragon
would probably spoil upcoming episodes
but it's safe to say that veigar the
biggest living dragon in the world is
out there certain to swoop in at a
critical moment
[Music]
you